welcome back so we've been talking about
fundamental limitations on robustness
and stability and shaping loop transfer
functions and sometimes you can invert
your plant model and shape your loop
transfer function by designing your
controller K so that your loop look has
desirable properties but in general
inverting plant dynamics can be a pretty
bad idea
so I want to give you some very
cautionary tale so like let's say I have
some plant P and I have some controller
K and I'm going to try to invert P so
that I get a good transfer function so
that the transfer function looks like
one something like that
well let's say that P equals let's make
it okay let's make it s plus 10 divided
by s minus 5 so we're a little tossed
transform domain this is a system with a
pole a right half-plane pole and s
equals plus 5 and so if I draw this in
the complex plane I have a pole at s
equals plus 5 and I have a zero way out
here at s equals minus 10 and we know
that a pole in the right half plane is
unstable because this 1 over s minus 5
corresponds to something in the time
domain that looks like e to the plus 5t
which blows up exponentially in time so
this is an unstable plant and if I try
to invert this plant with K we get into
this terrible terrible situation where
let's say ok so let's say I try to
invert this and I say K equals F minus 5
over s plus 10 sounds like a good idea
I can just multiply these I get K times
P equals 1 but let's say this is my
model let's say that P true equals s
+10 over and here I'm going to draw this
as s minus five plus Epsilon let's say
that I'm point oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh one
percent off of that pole
so I'm stead of it being here it's right
next to it okay I'm a tiny bit up my
true model has an unstable pole a little
bit off from where I thought this pole
was now if I look at P times K or I hit
it with K then PS if I look at P times K
now P true what I end up with is s minus
five over s minus five plus epsilon and
this is about as bad as you could
possibly have for a system so let me
walk you through this now I have a
system where essentially I still have a
pole very close to s equals five so I
still have a pole here the system is
still actually unstable there's this
unstable exponential growth at e to the
5 minus epsilon T but now I also have a
0 at s equals 5 like really really close
here and I should have drawn my X a
little to the left but maybe epsilon is
a little negative number anyway I have a
pole that is really unstable and a zero
right next to it and so what this means
is that this unstable mode is merely
unobservable so if we go back to our
state space observability
controllability if I have a 0 in the
right-half plane at s equals 5 then
anything near s equals 5 is going to be
really really hard to observe and so
what's going to happen is my system is
going to grow exponentially and I'm
barely even going to be able to see it
in my output Y so internally my system
is going to be blowing up and my
measurements not even going to tell me
it's blowing up so this is as bad as it
can possibly get where your system is
actually unstable and it's unobservable
ok so I can't even tell
that internally my system is blowing up
and going to hell okay so it's a really
bad idea if you ever have a system with
the right half-plane pole do not try to
invert it or cancel it because if you're
even an epsilon off all hell breaks
loose your system will be unstable and
it'll be unobservable it's basically as
bad as you can possibly get okay so if
you have right half-plane zeros you have
to do something else to try to stabilize
the system yeah okay so that's and also
if I had a right half-plane if I had a
right half-plane zero I also couldn't
invert that because then my controller
would be unstable it would have a right
half-plane pull so both of those are
hard to deal with this is just a very
simple example but I want you to be
aware the inverting new systems requires
extreme caution okay thank you